CBS News legal analyst Ricky cleeman
joins us now at the table Ricky I see
people on both sides of the aisle
rolling their eyes about this most
people believe he had the affair most
people believe the money has been paid
Michael Cohen has certainly talked about
it repeatedly so how strong is the case
and why is it coming about now well we
have to remember as the district
attorney would tell us the law is the
law and whoever violates it should be
prosecuted for no matter how long it
takes no matter how long it takes as
long as it is within the statute of
limitations however is it unusual in
2023 to look back to a case in 2016 when
Michael Cohen the main person who is the
witness in this case pled guilty in 2018
and keep in mind the southern district
of New York the federal government
passed on going forward against Donald
Trump when he left the presidency the
federal election commission passed so
now we have a new Sovereign in the state
who says it doesn't matter I have the
right to enforce the law in New York
County and here I see not only
falsification of business records which
are misdemeanors but I see a connection
to a campaign violation and that is a
felony and that's where Alvin Bragg is
as the D.A and he's going forward with
Vigor now some people may say as your
skeptical look and many other skeptical
looks around this is just my resting
face no that's right
this one well I think the argument is
wouldn't we have rather seen across the
country if you were going to take the
unprecedented step to go and indict a
former president wouldn't we have rather
seen it been about January 6th wouldn't
we have rather seen that it was in
Georgia about election interference but
we don't have the luxury of the rather
it turned out that Alvin Bragg became
aggressive in 2023 about a case that we
thought was long forgotten and it may
end up being that those other cases uh
come to some sort of a head but what
could happen in this case in the near
term for Mr Trump well everyone
he will be indicted
um I do not have any thought that he
will be quote unquote arrested tomorrow
what will happen is someone like Donald
Trump president former president or not
a white-collar crime he will get to
self-surrender and he will get to do
that because of the safety concerns here
which are Monumental because of his
safety the D.A safety everyone's safety
but he is protected by secret service
and secret service is not going to
parade him in handcuffs on a public way
he may go to an undisclosed location he
may go to the courthouse I expect it to
happen soon but not tomorrow all right
not tomorrow we'll keep watching it I'm
sure we'll have you back when if and
when it does happen Ricky Clement thank
you very much thank you appreciate it